The Black Death was one of the most
devastating pandemics in human history.
Between 1347 and 1351,
it wiped out 30% to 50%
of the entire population of Europe.
And if there's one animal to blame,
it's likely infected fleas,
making them one of the
deadliest insects in history.
Now, of course, fleas no
longer kill millions of people.
But as it turns out, they
still transmit plague,
they're still a nuisance,
and they're still incredibly
difficult to kill.
Fleas are one of the
oldest pests on the planet.
In fact, primitive fleas
were dining on dinosaur blood
about 165 million years ago.
And they're also one of the most abundant.
Today, there are more than 2,500 species
of fleas across the
world, like the cat flea.
Those are the ones you're
most likely to find
feasting on your dog or your cat.
And then there are species
like the human flea,
which actually seek out
human hosts specifically.
And seeking is a flea's specialty.
They can sense your breath, your warmth,
and even the vibrations of your feet.
And when they find you,
they do what fleas do best:
jump.
According to one study,
some fleas can jump
nearly 100 times farther than
the length of their body,
which would be like an average man
jumping nearly 175 meters into the air.
The secret to their spring
is a stretchy protein
in their legs called resilin,
and it works like a rubber
band in a slingshot.
Elizabeth Warburton: They
have kind of a hook-and-latch
type of system.
And when the flea lets go of
the latch, they just jump.
Narrator: Now, that makes
fleas difficult to capture
and kill, but it's what
they do once they land
that makes them a truly terrifying pest.
First, they use blades in their mouth
called maxillary laciniae
to tear into your flesh.
Then they use a straw-like structure
called an epipharynx to slurp it all up.
It's not unlike...
Warburton: If you spilled
your drink on a table
and you took a straw and
you tried to drink it up.
[slurping]
Narrator: Yum.
Adding insult to injury,
fleas have proteins
in their saliva that
keep your blood flowing
so they have a constant supply of food.
And that's actually why they itch so much.
Your body (or your pet's) is
reacting to those proteins.
But there's one flea that takes feeding
to another, more horrifying level.
And, unfortunately, it
prefers to prey on humans:
Tunga penetrans, aka the chigoe flea.
Instead of drinking blood
from the surface of your skin,
the females burrow into you,
and then they start laying eggs.
Warburton: Most of her
is buried into the skin,
but kind of the back part,
where she's releasing eggs,
is exposed.
Narrator: And fleas lay a lot of eggs.
Up to 40 each day and as many
as 2,000 in their lifetimes.
So if your dog brings back
a few fleas from the park,
you could soon have thousands.
And the truth is they can do a
lot worse than make you itch.
You see, even modern fleas
can transfer diseases
like typhus, bartonellosis,
and, yes, plague.
In fact, in the summer of 2019,
the discovery of prairie dogs infected
by plague-ridden fleas shut
down parts of a Denver suburb.
And in 2015, a teen reportedly died
from contact with fleas
infected with bubonic plague.
Now, fortunately, fatal
fleas are pretty rare,
and most likely it'll
be your pets, not you,
that have to deal with them.
But if you do see one
or two jumping around,
you definitely should
try to get rid of them.
And here's how.
First, identify the source.
And if it's your pet,
treat them with an insect growth
regulator, like Lufenuron.
Next, clean your home, though
you might want to steer clear
of flea bombs or foggers;
they're inconvenient
and don't always reach
the nooks and crannies
where fleas are hanging out.
Instead, repeatedly
vacuum or mop your floors
and toss any bedding
into the washing machine,
making sure to dry it at high heat.
After that, all you can do is sit, wait,
and hope that you're flea-free.